ينضم الان الينا من برلين مراسلنا عيسى
الطيبي ومن امام البرلمان في لندن
مراسلتنا مينا حربلو ومن موسكو مدير
مكتبنا زاورشاوج اهلا بكم جميعا همم من
وعيسى وجاور وابدا معك زاور اذا واضح
الاستياء الروسي واضح من رفع وتيره
المساعدات العسكريه من خلال هذه الدبابات
المختلفه الاوروبيه والامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا ولكن في المقابل يقول انه لن
يغير مسار الحرب كيف
نعم ليلى هو اشياء واضح ومتوقع هو دليل
اخر ترى موسكو ااا انه بيت امداد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات الغربيه هذا تدخل ومشاركه
مباشره وهذا ما تحدث عنه الجانب الروسي في
اكبر من مناسبه ولكن من الواضح ايضا من
التصريحات الروسيه انها لا تتعامل مع
تقديم هذه الدبابات على انه سيحدث كارثه
وقالت انها ستدمر وتحاول السلطات الروسيه
وحتى وسائل الاعلام الروسيه همم اظهار
اداء هذه الدبابات تحديدا الامريكيه في
العراق
وليابار في عام 2016 في منطقه الباب في
سوريا كيف دمرت هذه الدبابات وانا لا يوجد
سلاح لا يمكن تدبيره روسيا ما يكفي من
القدرات لمواجهه اي نوع من انواع اسلحه
هذا ما جرى مع غيرها من الاسلحه التي
قدمها حلف شمال الاطلسي همم الى اوكرانيا
ولكن بالنسبه لروسيا ترى ان الغرب اصبح
ينتقل من الحرب للوكاله على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الى الحرب المباشره مع روسيا
وانا لهذا الامر يمكن ان تكون تداعياته
بما في ذلك على التسويه الممكنه همم مع
اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق بتغيير وضع العمليه
العسكريه هنا همم كانت تطرح اسئله هل
سيعلموتن اعلان حرب على اوكرانيا ام سابقه
في اطار عمليه عسكريه خاصه من الواضح عن
الكريم لا يريد التوجه بعد الى اعلان حاله
الحرب همم مع اوكرانيا وهذا يعني همم ان
سيبقى العمل العسكري محدود في اطار عمليه
عسكريه خاصه لانها الحرب تحتاج همم عسكري
تعبير كلها الاقتصاد الروسي وهذا ما لا
يريده همم في هذا الوقت على الاقل
وبالتالي فقط ليله همم في حال وصلت هذه
الدبابات الان بعد اشهر لا نعرف بالضبط
ولكن في حال وصلت هذه الدبابات هذه ستكون
اول مواجهه بين القوات الروسي بين الجيش
الروسي حلف الناتو تاريخيا على ارض كانت
سابقا في الفضاء السوفيتي السابق وتدخل
الان في الفضاء الاستراتيجي وهذا يعني ان
المواجهه تنتقل الى مرحله مختلفه همم
حساسه جدا خطره يمكن ان ااه تذهب الى
عواقب وخيمه تهدد لها من القوم والاقتصاد
وهذا ما يكرره اساس روسي
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن التعبئه
العامه جديده موجه جديده من التعبئه
العامه في روسيا بنهايه الشهر هل من
تعليقات على هذا الكلام
بشكل سريع لو سمحت
تعبئه الجزئيه انتهت ولا يوجد حاجه لاني
القوات
اضافيه وبالتالي لا يمكن القول ان هناك
حتى اي اشارات
لتعبئه او جزئيه جديده متوقعه على الاقل
هذا ما نرى
سوف ترسل الى اوكرانيا بهذا تقول موسكو ان
بريطانيا ستدخل في مواجهه صريح الان في
هذه الحرب كيف هي الاصداء في بريطانيا على
هذه التصريحات
وبريطانيا لا تبدو ااا تبالي لهذه
التصريحات القادمه من موسكو خصوصا ذلك بان
بريطانيا ترى بانما تقدمه لي اوكرانيا هو
لمساعدتها على الدفاع عن نفسه عن اراضيها
وزير شؤون الدفاع وزير الدوله لشؤون
الدفاعيه اليكس تشوك الذي كان يتحدث امام
البرلمان البريطاني قال بان المرحله
المقبله في حرب اوكرانيا من حيث الدعم
الحلفاء بما في ذلك بريطانيا لاوكرانيا
ستؤكد ستركز بالدرجه الاولى ليس فقط على
مساعده القوات الاوكرانيه لمقاومه القوات
الروسيه بل ايضا على مساعدتها على اخراج
القوات الاوكراني الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله الوزير كان يتحدث عن
ان بريطانيا
لاوكرانيا بنهايه مارس المقبل وان
التدريبات ستبدا همم الاسبوع المقبل
ممكن الجنود الاوكرانيين من استخدام هذه
الدبابات صراحه بالوزير ايضا
بمقامه به
عفوا بما قامت به امريكا وايضا الالمانيه
بتسليم دبابات ل همم بولندا دبابات
لاوكرانيا عفوا ذلك لانه يرى بان المرحله
الحاسمه في الحرب الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا هي
همم يعني يجب ان تكون اوكرانيا يعني تتلقى
التعزيزات العسكريه المطلوبه في هذه
المرحله الجديده من الدبابات القتاليه
ايضا من مضادات الصواريخ والجمع ايضا
بينها وبين انظمه دفاعيه دقيقه لاستهداف
القوات الروسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
المحتله البريطانيه السر على حسب التعبير
الوزير البريطاني على صمودها وحزمها من
اجل دعم اوكرانيا مهما تتطلب الامر ذلك
لان الامر البريطانيين بشكل عام لا يخص
اوكرانيا واحده بل ان الامر يخص اوروبا
كامله هو كامله وايضا امنها
وامنها وسلامتها وسلامه اراضيها في ظل هذه
الحرب التي تعتقد بريطانيا بان غير شرعيه
على اوكرانيا
وماذا عن لابرد اثنين في المانيا همم عيسى
الردود الفعل على التحذيرات الروسيه من ان
الحرب الان تدخل مواجهه مختلفه من نوع اخر
مع دول اوروبا التي تصدر هذا النوع من
السلاح تفضل
المانيا الحزم تمراها وانتهى الموضوع الان
الذهاب الماني كما تقول الذهاب الانمي
لتسريع عمليه التسليم وايضا التسريع عمليه
التصنيع
وفضلنا عن ذلك اريد فقط نذكر بشيء حدث
اليوم وهي الزياره التاريخيه لوزير الدفاع
الالماني بورس باستوريوس الى الكتيبه
اللوجستيه او قوات التدخل السريع وهي راس
حربه النيته في شرق المانيا في ولايه
سكسونيا انهارت في مركز التدريب القتالي
قام وهذه ربما سابقه لم نحدها ان يكون
طبعا ان يعينها رجل في منصب وزير الدفاع
ولكن ان ان يلبس المعطف العسكري هذا اليوم
هي سابقه تاريخيه نتحدث عن الوزيرات
وزيرات الدفاع كانت انثى من ايام
ثم ثم كريستيان
بالملامح المانيه المعهود العسكريه يدخل
هذا الغمار يدخل داخل الدبابه
مع الجنود عن قرب همم الامر الثاني
هو ان الوزير اليوم في الاسئله تجنب
الاجابه عن بعض الاسئله لكنه اجاب عن
اسئله اخرى من بينها انه لا تاخيره في
موقف المانيا اذا اقرار ارسال دبابات
ليبارت اثنين وقال بان فان ما هو ضروري
وبان الجميع مرتاح لهذا القرار الامر
الثاني قال بان
الجنود الاوكرانيين وهذه من النقطه مهمه
بانهم سيبداون نهايه هذا الشهر الشهر
الجاري ونتحدث عن ايام القلائل التدرب على
الدبابات من طراز خفيف همم الدبابات لما
ارض الالمانيه ومن ثم قال سيبدا مباشره
التدريب على دبابات هنا في المانيا الامر
الثالث هو تحدث ايضا الوزير بان الدبابات
الالمانيه يتوقع ان تصل في بدايه مارس الى
الى اوكرانيا وقال بان هذا تاخير ليس هو
تاخير وانما هي عمليه لوجيه يتطلب هذا
الوقت الر سعر الداخليه الالمانيه لا تزلك
كلها مؤيدا لهذا القرار نتحدث عن المعارضه
بشكلها الاكبر سواء كانت من المسيحيين
الديمقراطين او من حلفاء شولدز من الخضر
والليبراليين كلهم الان يقفون معه في هذه
الخطوه خطوه لسنه الدبابات الامر الاخو
وهي برلين تريد ان تكون لدى اوكرانيا
الثلاث كتائب من الدبابات الكتيبه الاولى
التي تشارك فيها المانيا باسلحتها من
الدبابات الاسبانيه
والهولنديه ثم الكتبه الثانيه البولندي
النرويجيه والكاتبه الثالثه
بالانجليزيه فقط للتوضيح شكرا جزيلا لك
عيسى الطيبي من برلين شكرا لمينا همم حرب
له تحت المطر في امام البرلمان البريطاني
وشكرا لزاور شارج من موسكو مدير مكتبنا
شكرا